- Hey guy, how's it going?
It's Justine and guess
where we are right now,
we are in Seattle and
right now in front of me
is an old Apple store,
because behind me is a brand
new one that is opening
in University Village, here in Seattle.
Because this store was
opened in September in 2003,
which was before the iPhone,
which is kind of crazy to think,
there was a time before the iPhone.
So I look forward to the grand
opening of this tomorrow.
Oh my gosh people are clapping.
Sorry now all of the employees are waiting
for the last customer in
this Apple store to come out
and they're going to clap for him.
He's at the Genius bar right now,
and he has no idea what's
going to happen.
(crowd cheering)
(crowd clapping)
Definitely was focused on the
wrong guy leaving the store.
(speaker laughing)
So I don't even think I captured it.
This is the brand new store
that will be opening up
tomorrow morning, 9:30 AM.
Grand opening, baby.
(mysterious techno music)
The store looks amazing.
Oh my goodness!
It looks so good, I can't wait.
Hey Jen, is that a Ronin-S?
- [Jen] Are you a Ronin-S
or you just gonna, suh.
- Suh.
(speakers laughing)
(mysterious techno music)